um
and this is no one's going to believe
you
i'm going to tell you this thing and
you're going to go ah mike you don't
know what he's talking about
they say well what was he like this is
quiet
shy introvert very well mannered
i believe it you know but everybody else
says i don't believe it that's not what
i'm seeing in the music that's not what
i'm hearing
all i'm saying to you is that his art
as it came out of him
is what you're seeing
the poetry part of it i'm just going to
talk about poetry which i know nothing
about
i walk into a room he's there he says to
me
oh you got to read this great poetry
book some
known poetry book i'm thinking
hey dude this is mike over here what are
you talking about
poetry i'm into you know being masculine
you know i mean i'm being silly but
i'm going out dally even talking about
poetry who the hell you think
what poetry but
he was way into that
and what bob dylan was writing was heavy
heavy heavy poetry
what jimmy's writing when he's talking
about um
[Music]
when cries mary or you know all those
kind of songs where
you know he's talking about you can see
happiness staggering on down the street
footprints dressed in red he's telling a
story
from his point of view in his mind he's
talking about this
and he knows that this
is like very shocking to the society
meaning i'm
on the phone with him once i'm
calling him from new york i mean i'm in
new york with him
i'm calling tony and i'm saying
what about this what about that we do
our business that we had to do at that
moment
and i say uh
tony sends her regards or her love or
whatever
and jimmy says tell her i'll meet her in
the next world and don't be late
meaning this is jimmy this is in his
song
but he's living in another place that
you and i
can't imagine you get a clue of it by
his music
and you say oh this is some cool place
but
to sort of the beginning yeah talking
about his personality
personally some of the most talented
people that i know i've ever met have
been very socially awkward and
introverted
like that i wouldn't say he's socially
awkward i would just say
introverted quiet shy
very well-mannered and
he knows how to
get through a situation whatever it is
meaning
you know in his hotel room
in downtown tampa in the sheridan
there's a paper bag on the you know
little table there
i didn't think anything of it you know
we're doing the clothes and we're taking
the order and
this and that and and this is at the
first time we're meeting them and i say
oh let's figure out your size try these
pants on
meaning i could just look at him in one
second i could tell you what size he is
i give him the pants he walks over
towards the bathroom
there's one of those thin tables by the
bathroom
and he takes off the scarves that are
tied around his waist
which this is like a two minute job i
mean he's got knots
of scarves going around his waist and
around his waist just what he's doing at
the time
it's just what he's wearing yeah yeah
over his pants okay
he's wearing scarves and he's tying the
scarves around his knees and
you know wearing that stuff you see
anyway
he takes it off lays it on this table
takes the pants goes into the bathroom
two minutes later he comes back out
with his original pants on and he's got
the pants that i gave him to try on
he says make them all like this meaning
he's saying don't measure me
don't touch me whatever make them all
like this
fine i mean he's shy
and those pants fit them but these are
tight pants
and they're tight partially because
they're seamed down the front and back
and i can get away with it meaning we're
getting known for this look
of these pants with the buttons down the
side and all that
um but all i'm saying to you is that
he could get through a situation later
on that day after he played now
myself you know a few other guys and
girls or whatever
back at his room after the gig you know
the
the reefers being rolled we're smoking
it
you know half an hour goes by and
everyone's looking around they're hungry
you know someone takes out a piece of
paper and tries to take an order
you want a burger from the whatever
downstairs or
fries the first person tries to do it
they can't write they can't even spell
their own name
meaning they're too high second purse
too high third person too high
finally jimmy says give me the pet he
takes it
he asks do you want a burger you want a
medium you want fries you want this you
want a coke you want
he had to have been a
waiter at some point in his life or he
knew about this stuff
he wasn't ashamed of it or anything like
that this is what it took to do the job
he says give me the paper and he wrote
right gets the whole thing written out
they went and got the food we ate the
food that was the end of that
but all i'm saying to you is that
it's a very natural person and that's
what's coming across when he's telling
me
don't be hesitant to take and make
something anything to your fancy
as long as it's specially made as art
he's telling me mike
go for it just go and enjoy it just go
and make it don't worry about the money
don't worry about the time don't worry
about jimi hendrix don't worry about
anything
just go make some art and then send it
to me
and make a lot um so
all i'm saying to you is that this
is a lesson in life of
this is just another person
with all the things that you have he may
have a different set of talents and a
different way of
operating a little bit but and obviously
a very different destiny so far
in in your life anyway um but all i'm
saying to you is that
he knew how to communicate
on a record he knew how to communicate
with some fool that's making his clothes
in tampa you know or saint petersburg at
the time
um so there's a beauty to
just being natural that's really what he
was you know where a lot of us
feel as though you know i can't be
natural i'm not sp i got to play this
part that's
what the culture is telling me is proper
or cool or
you know whatever right you know and
what he's saying just go for it mike
you know do what you do right that's why
he chose you
so